oh my god what is wrong with him
Christmas withdraw it happens every year
is he gonna snap out of it maybe with a
little Christmas Bloody Mary come on
buddy
it's perfect for any Christmas hangover
it's blended fruitcake with just a hint
of eggnog mmm mmm
okay well maybe if we take him to the
theater and show him some traditional
Christmas movies good idea you think
we'll find a film about Christmas
showing Malcolm no movies about
Christmas come around this time of year
but you said Christmas movies oh well I
meant like a movie that comes out around
Christmas not about the Christmas Oh
like we could take him to one of these
true story movies a bunch of those come
out this time of year or how about one
of these fantasy films there's always a
few of those playing - yeah actually one
of those ties into the category of
people making musicals who shouldn't be
making musicals musicals as well as the
expense of kids films nobody attempted
to make good yes we always do have the
Oscar bait white guilt films now what is
that one oh this year it's Selma but
before it was The Blind Side 20 years of
slave Django no kidding yeah I love
those movies because the Critical always
takes me out to dinner afterwards boy
oh that's just the kids screening at the
Care Bears Nutcracker people want to see
that dude they're only playing it
because it was cheap to get Oh critic
are you seriously saying that you want
to sit there a bunch of whiney brats so
that you can watch something slightly
christmas-related sam worth it
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to all
right I've had my post-christmas fixed
it's time to move on to more serious
stuff let's talk about Care Bears
after reviewing what i suppo is this the
Care Bears movie trilogy a lot of people
were complaining that there was one more
film for me to look over the Care Bears
a nutcracker
in actuality this was a one-hour episode
of the TV series that's why it opens up
with the theme song and characters who
don't appear in the special at all this
is actually kind of funny because I can
wonder what the poor people who never
saw the show are thinking when they pop
this DVD in wait why is there a little
girl version of Doc Brown next to one of
Ghibli's hair balls wait when did some
of the Care Bears start wearing
seriously dated clothes did the wizard
from Fantasia become a Klansman recently
nevertheless in the spirit of
post-christmas depression I suppose I
can give in and still review this
horse let's finish off the Care Bear
saga before we get into the stuff that
gets somehow weirder later time for game
of disappearing brain cells this is the
Care Bears Nutcracker we open with a
school production of what else the
Nutcracker as apparently not all the
performers are on board you said it was
gonna have a lot of fights and battles
in but there are a lot of fights and
battles in the show some versions even
have a Holocaust if you're desperate
enough my favorite version of the story
was told to me by some friends of mine
the Care Bears
we're gonna use this view in our show
this is our concern dude I've just
spotted a little girl down on earth
through the star telescope her name is
Anna and she's really sad what but it's
Christmas everybody should be happy you
know don't the Care Bears have anything
other than first world problems
yeah what about some of these ruthless
dictators that have been slaughtering
the innocent couldn't we maybe shift
their emotions so they don't want to do
that anymore no no we mostly just deal
with the white ones Oh
any particular reason where they stop of
greeting cards who else are we gonna
appeal to me so funshine bear Takes
grumpy bear to go with which I'm only
now realizing how strange it is that
he's a part of all this why is there a
care bear named grumpy isn't like I like
going to a psychiatrist named lunatic
we're still gonna buy buff TTIP songs we
don't give a everything gets wrong
you'll soon see this tune with Kara's
now we know it's pretty lame athlete to
connect a this to the damn ballet but it
shuts your kids so calm the down
so after committing vehicle aside I'm
assuming it was alive it did have a face
they fold down the chimney of the girl
they're supposed to help
well you and most white suburban
teenagers so they go into the room of
our sad girl named Anna and is it me or
do the Care Bears have the habit of
helping the exact same looking type of
girl every single time there really is
some prejudice going on here
ma'am we have another sad little girl on
the corner we have blond hair and blue
eyes I don't know what that has to do
with it like the question well no she's
a brunette with green eyes no interest
but she's threatening others with the
machine one day my pure we will build
the master race but is luck with
freaking habit Anna's house is the exact
same random location of a portal to
another world
it happens usually carebears in the
house so they come across a nutcracker
who should clearly be called the voice
cracker due to his puberty pipes I can't
remember my name I've even lost my arm
thanks for straightening me up
if only I was built with testicles so
they were trapped as he soon followed by
some rodent bed he's led by the Rat King
if only no the only thing this guy would
be the king of is being the villain in a
fast-food commercial look out
it's the Rat King he ruins Happy Meals
a code so her brother named Peter gets
involved as the Care Bears tried to use
peaceful talks to calm down the ran haha
just kidding the Pete they should have
them only here and in my pot induced
dreams will that ever make sense both
the Nutcracker suddenly gets back part
of his memory they work for the evil
Vizier who's trying to control all of
Toyland
yes Lavery
so after escaping the scene on the
stairs they go back to having another
scene on the stairs what just an
expensive location you want to get your
money's worth
all of a sudden should have paid your
background artists mil okay so the Care
Bear stare has a lot more power than I
gave it credit for
apparently it can also open up doorways
to other dimensions and send bad guys
back through it I have a radical idea
the door swings both ways we could
reverse the particle flow through the
gate how the Care Bear stare I love this
so let's explain that the Rat King works
for the evil Vizier who has taken over a
toy land and thus the Care Bears need
backup in order to save it
it's fun shining Grumpy's distress
signal signal Oh Care Bears they got it
so those are the gang arrived to help
each sold separately man even people who
like this show can't stand you too so
Peter is left behind to babysit them but
hugs and tugs to be quite the little
worm tongs think of all the special
Christmas tree ornaments we could find
there okay kids I don't know what your
weird ornament fetish is all about but
it's clearly not worth death actually
yes it is happy hunting wait down there
one that looks dangerous have you
consider wearing these jackets this
story is really great Thank You Holly
but don't we have some rehearsing to do
the rest of the evening will be
carebears relieved but they have to go
home in five minutes no you don't you're
with me now
so the piscina is trying to get
information from the captured sugarplum
fairy about the location of the hidden
magic ring that'll give him
uncontrollable power and again is it me
or does this character look exactly like
the previous villain they had in the
last Care Bears movie are the designers
of these specials literally given no
time to draw new characters we need a
new cameras villain in 20 seconds it's
not very good I don't care so the Care
Bears find the is trained they can
with the Cubs hopping a board as well
the fussier watches in dismay yarn
little wooden Randy's do
honestly I'm starting to get the idea
they just took the first take with every
line on this guy that's how it's toilet
I Christmas okay mmm good vocal warmup
now let's do a wheel we got it we're
good but that was the equivalent of me
clearing my throat no no no we're good
you do realize I want to be hired by
other people after this project car
you
so they enjoy some of the treats of
Toyland without even taking the wrappers
off I don't give a as they right
through various enchanted locations many
of them spelled wrong and continue to
look around their unfinished mariokart
levels and welcome to an early preview
of your nightmares tonight it's like if
cereal mascots what's wrong with rat
poison instead of ink my particular
favorite is this clown with horns on his
head who would do that we weren't
attacking you
we just wanted your train different well
no but if you were smart do you do what
my friends and I are trying to do yeah
out of toilet yeah but but we're here to
save toilet
yeah but I'm sorry why does he still
have the horns on his head we realize
now these were innocent creatures who
are beat up and such but what innocent
creatures have horns on their heads I
mean okay I'm not anti horn but no
people sensibilities I'm anti horn honey
you won't believe what the Nostalgia
Critic said about us bitch oh did this
to you
it's a long story well we have all the
time you need actually you don't whether
it's saving toilet or finally wrapping
up to do some ballet rehearsing
time it's not something you have an
abundance of here the day when the
Vizier and his army of rats overthrew
the Prince of Toyland
no one knows for sure some say he was
killed in a big fight with the Vizier
yeah
I really wonder who the the prince
is with that incredibly not distinct
design I suppose it could be anyone I
mean Jesus Christ you showed him right
there you even forgot to animate them as
a human instead of a nutcracker it's not
really much of a twist if you spotlight
what the twist is going to be surrounded
by just follow me ridiculous
keep laughing at him gingerbread men and
injured clouds hey you want sauce don't
Brandon so will they head closer to the
castle the red king's army gets ready to
attack with okay who smoked one guys I
can't believe I'm about to say this but
we're about to be whole go to death as a
sidenote it's weird that my spell Jeff
recognized that has word
boy the campers don't use as much caring
in this one as much as vengeful violence
yeah that peaceful friendly smile does
great at pummeling your enemies into
submission for that matter why does the
elephant have a cowbell on his stomach I
don't see the connection
Peter along with hugs and tugs gets
captured and thrown in a jail cell
I don't know hugs we'll never find our
own special Christmas ornament in there
for fuck's sake what is your obsession
with this goddamn Christmas ornament
they're gonna come up your balls or do
God knows what Tia that's King destroy
the bear comes to right that was weird
but the rest of them eventually get to a
boat in which grumpy is the only one
rowing
why doesn't universe hate him so much
until they reached the castle and split
up
well that was pointless the game history
pillar for the music hey something has
to remind us this was based on something
good
meanwhile the kids try to figure out a
way to escape I was born in the doll
they trick him into getting locked
inside as the others find the Sugar Plum
Fairy and ask her where the ring is
you mean the ring was in that the
thought occurs to me that the fairy can
fly so this is all kind of pointless I
mean what if we were to fall the nut
flies out of our hands into the fishes
hands who grabs the fairy covers us and
taffy and you know I'm gonna stop
talking puts my nuts in your mouth and
bite hard I don't give a how that
sounds I'm in a cab a movie so he starts
to turn his friends to wood until he
finally agrees to open the nut you'll
get his ring no really what about
Christmas how does this in any way
affect Christmas even if they die I
think Jesus is still born this comes
much to the fishery strangely delivered
delight
i won as I knew I would
are you sure you don't want me to do
another take
are you listening to your iPod so then
the cracker opens the nut in a way that
has nothing to do with how nutcrackers
open nuts and the fairy puts it on his
finger turning him back into a boy whoa
I know Toyland is mine
so damn weird Weaver's beam powers your
reign is over Vizier and now as Prince
of toilet I command the Vizier spell
over the land to be gone so if the ring
could do all this the whole time why the
hell did they hide it in the first place
wouldn't it make more sense to use its
power so that the fussier didn't take
over Toyland no no it's cool we're just
gonna wait for all the people to be
enslaved beaten and tortured to death
before we play our big trump card
it seems stupider that way Oh be going
this way Allen Prince hello Anna
hello Allen so this was all a wet dream
just about our next-door neighbor where
the Care Bears just a metaphor for
losing your childhood innocence and from
that day forward Anna and Allen remained
the best of friends hello there are you
almost ready oh I'll be right with you
Allen
goodbye children and have a Merry
Christmas I'll just leave you kids
unsupervised to put on this show we're
apparently never going to perform oh and
by the way the Care Bears were also real
and yet a dream somehow but if your
stupid little minds around that one and
that was the Care Bears Nutcracker can I
finally stop with these it is what it is
a stupid but harmless special four
little little little little kids but
that still doesn't mean it isn't pasted
horribly or awkwardly done it's still
clumsy and lacking any imagination but
again what did you expect
it's careful it's at best a passable
distraction for your little kids
anything else about it is pretty much
just a waste of time if there are any
more goddamn Care Bear sequels to look
at when simply I don't care though
thanks for joining me throughout
December I hope you enjoyed it end wait
a minute next month's January you know
what that means
you
i won as I knew I would